thank you very much
it's it's wonderful
thank you
it's wonderful to see your beautiful
masks again
still with this [ __ ] yeah i know some so
much has changed we haven't been on for
a couple of months so much has not had a
birthday yesterday that changed
uh i i don't
know
please
so i don't see myself as getting older i
see myself as becoming a milder variant
[Applause]
yeah i got a new variant
well you know that today january 21st
this is the two-year anniversary when
they found the first case in america 34
year old man in seattle yes and i got to
tell this guy stop putting patient zero
on your tinder profile it's impressing
though
like
but we we didn't have omicron when we
were here a couple of months ago that's
the new one and that one's very
milder much milder we should be
celebrating this
but of course easier to very easy to
catch it's it's like the candy man just
to say its name five times you can get
this [ __ ]
uh
but
mild
but most people don't even know they
have it you know it's a
milder thing it's like you know it
shoots its viral load and you go wait
did you
so
anyway hopefully we're getting out of
this [ __ ] soon i mean i i can't take it
much more and by the way if you are two
years in if you're one of those people
who didn't get it at all and he and well
they must be
you must be very diligent very careful
and you have no friends
it would be my guess no
[Applause]
no this it's just gone on too long
nobody cares anymore the last night the
grubhub delivery guy was eating my
french fries right in front of me i mean
[Applause]
too long
people want to know when i can when can
i get back to not going to the gym
it's ridiculous you know
i don't want to live in your paranoid
world anymore your mass paranoid world
you know you go out it's silly now you
know you have your mask you have to have
a card you have to have a booster they
scan your head
like you're a
cashier and i'm a bunch of bananas
i'm not bananas you are
uh
okay so here's what i read today in the
paper that
new year 2022.
anybody remember the movie soylent green
classic futuristic movie from the 1970s
you know what year it took place
2022
so i was like i'm going to take this as
a note of optimism we're doing better
than that
at least we're not eating people
although with the prices at the
supermarket you don't know
uh yeah oh well you know biden's got to
deal with that biden's been having a
rough time he finally had to give a
press conference this week did you see
that it went on for two hours two hours
although the first hour it was just
about how kids bikes didn't used to be
so complicated so i
now they're trying to get
[Applause]
they're trying to feel good about
themselves it's not easy they made a
video did you see this with tom hanks
narrating where tom hanks says we are
strong we are courageous we are
resilient and this is the land of the
brave
now put that diaper back on your face
and go hide inside
and then
i love this
and then biden comes on
and he said
we have faced so much and we have what
we have done is what america has always
done we have gotten up that's what i
want a 79 year old president bragging
about getting up
that's right
america got up and now we're gonna make
a cup of sanka and check the mailbox
you